well it's a question many of us have
asked during the pandemic
it's one area of the valley more
affected by covid than anywhere else
and where are people catching
coronavirus it's a project our eye team
has been working on now for months our
own david charns is live on the east
side of the valley
with those answers david
brian we're at the intersection of
bonanza and lamb here in the heart of
89110
remember that zip code no part of the
valley has seen more cases
than where we are right now and one
local mother tells us
how she thinks she and her entire family
got kobit 19
and tonight she has a message for you
and other families at home
you know my youngest is seven and he
said like mom you know i know this
sounds
you know this sounds um bad but i'm glad
that i'm positive because i can hug you
yolanda martinez's youngest son
told her that once he too tested
positive for cobin 19.
the las vegas mom of three had already
been sick for a week
quarantined to her bedroom i would just
open the door to grab my food when they
would take it to me
within days the virus had infected her
entire family
i mean i never thought it was going to
hit my family as well
you know and when it did it's like
shocking it's like
it can happen to everyone the martinez's
make up some of the 11
000 in the valley zip code with the most
copic cases
89110 she also works here at the matter
academy
now a half year after getting sick
martinez tells the i-team
a family gathering may be to blame like
maybe three four families
small families including ours in all she
thinks
about 20 people were at that july 4th
party
all 20 got sick somebody had to have it
in order for all of us to get it while
she's not pointing to one specific
person
the only one she can fault is herself
and now as cases continue to spread in
her area faster than anywhere else
she hopes her story reminds others to
stay safe
i would say you shouldn't have done a
gathering with your family you should
have just
gathered you know had a fourth of july
with just your
household and you know and just
celebrated fourth of july that way
thankfully no one died and no one had to
be hospitalized
and now vaccinated and moving forward
martinez's message
is clear i should have just waited
until all this would have went away